our next script is titled miles by Joey
Clark jr. after losing their parents to
the opioid crisis a 12 year old girl and
her little brother run away from their
foster parents to get back to their dog
miles these are the foster parents
Samuel and Courtney doing their best to
welcome Riley and Nolan into their home
with a nice dinner in this scene Nolan
only six years old is still trying to
understand that his dad has died and his
mom is likely heading to prison while
Riley wants no part of her new living
situation interior coal home dining room
evening a steak potatoes asparagus red
wine for Courtney and Samuel Nolan
struggles to cut a steak do you need a
hand I should have thought of that I'm
sorry my mom cuts chicken smaller is
this better yeah why don't we see my mom
we're not get used to it why because the
law said well that's not entirely right
now the authorities feel it's you
shouldn't lie to him not everyone who
has kids is really the best for them
some people don't you know think that
but what Courtney is trying to say is
some people have kids before they're
ready maybe they have personal issues
they need to tend to first and that's
what I was about to say and some people
who are ready can't and they're willing
and able to serve as the parents for
little kiddies who need them that's us
oh you can't have kids
see my ovaries the place that makes
babies this her baby factory did we're
sick no you can say cancer but you have
to see baby factory
he knows what what cancer is it's
appropriate knowledge for six-year-olds
right well you're the adult
but I'm better now
I just can't have kids unless we were to
adopt which is where you come in Oh
banette sadly yes
potentially right um we're very happy
for the chance to help raise you for now
and if it does go that way then forever
does that make sense
Nolan doesn't eat a steak the others eat
in silence Courtney takes a noticeably
long gulp of wine
can you move my bed to Riley's room
interior call home Riley's room night
Samuel drags drags Nolan's mattress
through the door he drops it on the
floor
Courtney puts the sheets on Nolan
watches on holding his pillow maybe just
for a few nights until you're more
acclimated a clean comfortable did until
he more comfortable interior a cold home
restroom night Riley looks through the
drawer that she brushes her teeth hand
soaps towels then a small coin purse she
spits out the toothpaste curious she
opens the coin purse she finds two $20
bills she peeks out the bathroom door
from death from down the hall she can
hear her foster parents talking she sets
the cash on the counter and walks down
there to the door she listens through
the door we should take them to see
their mom before she goes to prison I
may be easy she's detoxing at the
University huh absolutely not
they're dumb dog would probably be more
comforting that's not a joke drug
addicts should not have kids should not
Roddy walks back to the bathroom and
pockets the cash
smart girl
[Applause]
[Music]